today we're talking about security and
sustainability
i'm jenny brown and welcome to this week
in cloud
where we serve you the lowest latency
news
google cloud has launched a security
solution web app and api protection
where we're combining three products to
provide comprehensive threat protection
for your web applications and
apis google cloud armor apogee
and recaptcha enterprise we've got an
on-demand webinar
a white paper and a solution page to
help you get started today
some of the most important data at your
company isn't living in databases
but in documents and most business
processes begin
involve or end with a document many
organizations are still
manually entering data and leaving heaps
of value on the table
in terms of better customer experiences
the latest release of document ai
platform
lending doc ai and procurement doc ai
built on decades of ai innovation at
google
bring powerful and useful solutions to
these challenges
check out the blog to learn more about
what's going on under the hood
from efficient data centers to
purchasing renewable energy at scale
google is dedicated to doing our part to
protect the environment
and planet chrome os provides
sustainable computing software and
hardware
through our ecosystem of partners and
customers from
energy efficiency to responsible supply
chain and operations
check out the link for more we've
launched an
updated version of our google cloud
security foundation's guide and
corresponding terraform blueprint
scripts
in these resources we provide
opinionated step-by-step guidance
for creating a secured landing zone into
which you can configure and deploy
your google cloud workloads from key
decision points to areas of focus
we provide the why behind our
recommendations
but of course you're free to do your own
thing check them out in our best
practices center
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list
check out the link any thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us
we'll see it in the cloud
you